wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jordan peterson
enjoy
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's a fairly it's a fairly
limited attempt first of all we're not
going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or other you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do
now some of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it
and see what happens and what will
happen is your vision will clear a
little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you could
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear
and final picture of what constitutes
the truth
and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start you
don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt
a mode of being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the depth by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 of our capacity
something i mean you can think about
this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day
you know inefficient studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there you know you think well that's 20
25 hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient 20
times more efficient that's the pareto
distribution you have no idea how
efficient efficient people get it's
completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that so
there's this weird dynamic that's part
of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are are are major
causes of suffering and the failure of
individuals to adopt the responsibility
that they know they should adopt it
isn't merely that your fate depends on
whether or not you get your act together
and to what degree you decide that
you're going to live out your own
genuine being it isn't only your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about nine billion by the way and
then it'll decline rapidly but seven
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust mote
among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion and so that's how you're
connected and the things you do they're
like dropping a stone in a pond the
ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really asked yourself would you be
so sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are when the
alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century you're actually tougher than you
think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
overprotected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity
you know so maybe you're a kid in the
playground right and you're having some
trouble with other kids and you know in
the back of your mind i should deal this
with deal with this myself but you go
and tell your mom and get her to
intervene and you know that that's not
right you know that you're breaking the
social contract but it's easier and so
that's what you do you run off to an
authority figure and hide behind the
great father right roughly speaking well
the problem with that is you don't learn
how to do it yourself so then you have
to relearn it painfully when you're 40.
so then you take people out
you say well
what are you afraid of rank it from 1 to
10.
so 10 is
make a list of 10 things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number 10. so we'll
start with that okay well i'm afraid of
elevators okay well let's let's look at
a picture of an elevator let's have you
imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in what's no longer the
elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that and then
you're met much more
together much more confident and that's
often one of the things that often
happens in situations like that i've
seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up built for struggle us human
beings you not after
the bubbles of bliss that dostoevsky
described in in notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in
but it's your best bet and you know
people have
also people that have extracted
unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures
and so and i'm not saying that in a
naive way i know perfectly well what
happens to people you know you're doing
fine in life and then you get cancer and
then six months later you're dead and
all the heroism in the world isn't going
to save you at that point but that's not
the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do
so it's it's it beats
laying in your basement getting bitter
and then doing the terrible things that
bitter people do
so
you can't ensure that the meaning you
experience is self-determined but you
can play your role to the best of your
ability and that will be good enough
and that will be good enough
that meaning
the meaning that you all find in then in
that
i believe is
sufficient to be sustaining and perhaps
even sustaining through the flood
so
it isn't that you can avoid catastrophe
it's that you can prepare yourself to
deal with it honorably when it arrives
that's what you've got now this the
baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just the
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too one of the things i've been talking
to my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying um
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons
but you need something to put
up against that
and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe
and most of that meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better
yeah that's better guilting yourself
you're not feeling bad about yourself
that's right you feel that you've
justified you've justified your
existence right and so you're not waking
up at three in the morning in a cold
sweat thinking about all the terrible
things that you've involved yourself in
what you said to someone that you
shouldn't have said or how you acted or
what opportunity you lost or or or yeah
or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that
and so
if you think about the times when you're
at peace with yourself with regards to
how you're conducting yourself in the
world it's almost always conditions
under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt i think that you can
experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that your
best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the if you being eaten wasn't a
real possibility it wouldn't be a real
fight
and so you see people like i've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
i had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything
at her disposal to do so
and i strategized with him for about
three years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much he got backed into a corner
so hard that i didn't know how to help
him anymore
so
i would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did
manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say he did manage to
establish what i think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got
enough out of what he did to justify it
even though
the whole landscape was pretty
awful
i think that
not lying is your best bet
but
life is hard and people get run over and
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to emerge in any obvious sense
triumphant
but
if you take the alternative path path
especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it
and that's something i had a plumber
once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and i
was going to test the joints these are
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and i said i told him i
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and i thought yeah that's
okay how about if i test them so i went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to and
like half an hour later i had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable
forthright productive way of making a
living and there is a hell of a lot of
difference between a working man who
knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of
egalitarian egalitarianism and equity
and they fail to recognize completely
that there are differences in rank
between people it's not such a terrible
thing man maybe you wouldn't be a great
lawyer like it's certainly possible most
people aren't but that doesn't mean
there isn't something you could be great
at there's lots of hierarchies to
attempt to climb and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what the hell are you going to do if
you don't try to aim for the top you
know flap about uselessly and whine
about your life it's not helpful it'll
just make you miserable you're not
reliable to anyone you can't help out in
a crisis it's like so you tell young
people and this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there make
something of yourself for god's sake be
an honest person and work and get to the
top of whatever it is that you want to
get to the top of you know and and and
and that stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard a month
ago month and a half used to teach there
and i talked to a bunch of students you
know and i told them it's not easy to
get into harvard you know like you're a
valedictorian if you're at harvard
and not only are you a valedictorian
you're way better than most people at at
least two other things or you don't get
in and so like it's i don't know what
the acceptance rate is like five percent
and believe me not everybody applies so
it's a very selective school and so why
am i saying that it's like these are
high quality kids so i told them what i
just told you it's like here you are at
harvard it's like get yourself educated
man read some books learn to talk learn
to think make yourself into something
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here happy that you
were put there in that great institution
you know
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out the other thing you should do if
you're not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more disciplined
like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tight
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 have non-proportional payoffs that's
part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome
if you really want to solve a
complicated problem maybe you try to
solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs this is
something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail
at
producing their creative product and
monetizing it right so your default
position if you're a creative person is
you're going to fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's j
and it's hard to
present it to the market at the right
time and it's hard to market it like
those things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and eventually if they're fortunate
one of their ideas happens to hit
the right place at the right time and so
that's also
darwinian in some sense you know you're
creating all these little enterprises
that are sort of alive
they're they're run by people after all
and even if your idea is good that
doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so this is partly why
persistence and that's part of
conscientiousness is so useful it's like
you know what are they safe if at first
you failed then try try again and um and
that would probably mean try something
different rather than the same thing
but
persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and and you need to know that the
baseline is failure
you know it's important because
otherwise you'll blame that on yourself
it's hard to say what the soul means
metaphysically because you know say
beyond the cons beyond the confines of a
single human being
we do have this sense that the soul can
expand itself into something that's
greater than
well greater than it has been it has
this capacity for growth
and we do have the sense that
the soul can expand itself to the point
where it it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible to transform
everything that's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
about the world into what's positive and
good and and and that it does that as a
consequence of confronting the world
with courage and truth and i i think
that's right
and i do think that that means that the
soul participates in something eternal
which is the attempt of being itself
to transform what's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
into what's good and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of the reason that our
ancient tradition insists that were made
in the image of god
and i think that it's a mistake to
underestimate the importance of that
because
i don't think that you can live
life a life of sufficient profundity to
protect yourself from being corrupted by
suffering malevolence without
adopting
a
responsibility that's commensurate with
that set of ideas
i think that you either
orient yourself upward
you know to the star above the horizon
and try desperately to improve the
structure of being
or you work at counter purposes to it
and make things worse i don't think
there's a middle ground
and in fact to the degree there is a
middle ground it tilts towards the
negative because people who try to
occupy the middle ground
try to
generally try to accrue the benefit
let's say without
adopting any of the risk and that's not
acceptable
not helpful
so
that's a soul to me i would say for the
last 45 years we've told
psychologists have been
have been certainly to blame for this at
least in part
you're okay the way you are that's what
we tell young people oh you're okay the
way you are it's like
and there's nothing worse than you can
tell that you can tell someone who's
young than that
especially if they're miserable you know
and lots of them well if they're
miserable and aimless it's like oh i'm
miserable and aimless and sometimes i'm
suicidal and i'm nihilistic and i don't
have any direction in your life it's in
my life it's like well you're okay the
way you are here and it's like they
don't want to hear that they want to
hear look you know
you're
and you know this you're
useless
you know nothing you haven't got started
you've got 60 years to put yourself
together and god only knows what you
could become
and that's so
that message is so much more it's so
funny because it's so
it's such an attack
but it's so positive
because there's faith there in the in
the potential that makes up the person
rather than the miserable actuality that
happens to be manifesting itself at the
moment and young people respond
extraordinarily well to that because
when you know that if you're a parent
and you love your
your child your son your daughter
what you're trying to foster
is the best in them you want that to
manifest itself across the course of
their life you want them to become
continually
more than they are to see what they
could be
and
well and i think that's part of the
great message of the west is that that's
that's the that's the ethical
requirement of individual
being in in in the proper sense is to
constantly
note that you're not what you could be
to take responsibility for that and to
and to
commit yourself like body and soul to
the attainment of that
ideal you have to
add
small goals now if that doesn't work
like if you can't make the goals small
enough to achieve you know it might be
that you're not being humble enough with
regards to your conceptions of your own
ability but
you can tell if the goal that you put
forward is a reasonable one if you're
actually implementing it because if
you're not then by definition it's not a
reasonable goal you know like let's say
you're you're sleeping all the time in
your room is just a bloody complete
disaster you know and you think well i
should clean up my room it's like well
maybe you can't but maybe tomorrow you
could hang up two shirts you know or you
could you could move two shirts from
your bedroom to the laundry room or you
could bag up a bag of dirty clothes that
you could conceivably take to a
laundromat and you just do that one
thing you know
if you do if your room's a catastrophe
and you do that one thing and then you
did one thing like that for 15 days or
20 days maybe your place would be in
order
and so the trick is to get the
trajectory right when you're moving
through life and you have a plan or a
dream and it shatters you know someone
dies or a relationship breaks apart or
you you have a terrible upset in your
career or you become ill in some
unexpected way then everything around
you falls apart and you plunge into a
well you plunge into a chaotic
underworld the belly of the way that's
exactly right yes exactly that and then
maybe you stay there because it isn't
necessarily the case that people get out
you know people die people are in
despair permanently but
frequently
something tragic and terrible befalls
you and you fall apart
and you learn something profound as a
consequence and you put yourself back
together and when you come back out
you're more than you were when you went
in and that's happening at a small scale
every time you learn something you know
you if you ever really learn something
it's usually painful it usually means
that you have to recognize that you're
wrong in some important way you have to
let that part of you that's wrong die
and then you have to let a new part of
you okay so the self imagine that
you undergo a series of transformations
in your life there are
there are collapses into the chaotic
underworld and then many resurrections
that happens continually and that's what
molds your character is the self is this
thing that
manages the transformations across all
those across that manages all those
transformations so you could say here's
another way of thinking about it
you could identify with what you
understand
that's what ideologues do you could
identify with you don't with what you
don't understand and that's what sort of
seekers
after truth
um
uh identify with or you could identify
with the process of moving between those
states you know sometimes you know what
you're doing you know where you are
you you're in control
and and and you can become arrogant and
identify with that and then become too
static about it right
or you can be in despair and everything
is chaotic and you can identify with
that in which case you're nihilistic or
you can view yourself as the thing that
moves across the transformations and
that's that's the right way to to to
conceptualize yourself as you're the
thing that maintains constancy across
transformations of course you struggle
to remember it in your day-to-day life
because life is difficult and it's
harder to do things than not to do them
and it's harder to do them well than to
do them badly you know and it's easy to
sit around and be hopeless i don't mean
it's emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and to fall back into your old habits
and to not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice and i think a good
example of that is something like weight
lifting you know if you start a weight
lifting program which i would recommend
by the way because it it's tremendously
advantageous physically and cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six-month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and i
did mention the future authoring program
um earlier and
one of the things i would recommend too
is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it
and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i'm not quitting
anymore you smoke a whole pack of
cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
um
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself properly if you're
pursuing them but you want them to be
small enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of implementing
them you should use a calendar to
structure your days
because if you know what you're doing
tomorrow it decreases your anxiety
substantially because you need that kind
of structure
you need a pathway you need to know
you need to have a map and you need to
know where you're located on the map and
you need to know how you're moving
forward and that gives you hope because
you're moving towards goals that you
regard as
worthwhile and it stops you from being
anxious because you're not entirely
directionless and lost
and so learning how to manage your time
is useful and you can start with a
calendar you can start with simple
things like you can put in well
when you're likely to go to bed and when
you're likely to get up and and
regulating that's useful that should be
relatively ritualistically consistent
you want to present yourself to the
world in a manner that
that doesn't disgrace you in some sense
that that might be a good way to think
about it and you don't want to disgrace
yourself because the consequence of
disgrace is is emotional dysregulation
more pain less positive emotion and so
the best way to present yourself is to
stand up forthrightly and to stretch out
you know and to occupy some space and to
to to you make yourself sort of
vulnerable by doing that because you
open up the front of your body right but
it's a sign of confidence and that way
people are most likely to give you the
benefit of the doubt
and that's a good way to start
regulating your mood but not only does
it directly regulate your mood to stand
up because it's so tightly associated
like posture reflection is associated
with serotonin and emotional regulation
but also because
if you straighten up and you present
yourself in that manner then other
people are more likely to take you
seriously and that means they'll start
treating you as if you're a number one
lobster instead of a number 10 lobster
and that's another way that you can
at least give yourself the bloody
benefit of the doubt right and and and
and and and and confront the world in a
courageous manner let's say you're a
filmmaker and i'm a professor
okay we could so we differ there
right we're playing a different game
so you might say
and and as you go down into the
particulars of what we do it might even
become more different so if you look at
what a plumber does and a lawyer does as
as you get more and more fine-grained
they get more diverse but you might say
well the lawyer and the plumber are both
honest
they're both good citizens
and then you might nest that inside
while they're both acting out the
archetype of the hero
and
and like i said after that you're out of
the
things get too abstract for us to we
can't go farther than that i think that
you know i think the world is
order versus chaos let's say the balance
of order and chaos on a it's good and
evil on the background of order versus
chaos
and so you're either the hero or the
adversary or actually most of the time
you're a mixture of both
and it's best for you that's what our
culture has decided it's best for you to
take on the role of the hero to the
degree that that's possible and that
would be associated with love and that's
that
the
love
and i define that in the second book
particularly
what's the third book i wrote but in
in beyond order
are you working for the betterment of
being or are you working for harm
and everyone has a sense of this
and they know when they're working for
harm we are thrown
challenges and that they're
that and that in some sense those are
best construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what jung thought his idea
was something like this that at the
beginning of time people were
unconscious
and that consciousness emerged with all
of its catastrophes consciousness of
death for example and
one way out of the burden of
consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness you can do that with
alcohol you can do that by being
dependent you can do that by failing to
grow up you refuse the burden of
consciousness by
becoming unconscious again but there's
another way forward which is to become
even more conscious so the idea would be
a little bit of consciousness is like an
illness but if you can expand that
consciousness upwards enough then it's
time something it starts to become
something that it's all that is its own
cure and that partly what your goal is
while you suffer through life is to
heighten your consciousness to the point
where everything gets integrated enough
so that that's proper medication for the
disease of self-consciousness saying
look it's good for you to go take your
place in the world have some ambition
have some have a vision have a goal have
a strategy try to try to be a good
person in not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that i've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learn to articulate better
is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what well that's whatever
your aspiration is you have to have an
aim okay well what should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say what why do something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile usually judge
them positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves but you want to be completely
useless so other people have to take
care of you that's pretty pathetic and
maybe you could get your act together so
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and maybe you could even do
better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community you have to negotiate until
you come to the best solution that can
be negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and if you get upset during
the negotiations which you likely will
because these are difficult topics how
to divide up responsibilities in the
house and people get mad because they
feel they've been taken advantage of or
aren't being listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got
the balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know and you
might have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
um maybe sometimes when you're
negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
going to agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it compare
yourself to who you were yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason i wrote that was because i had
this client 10 i'm a clinical
psychologist and i spent 20 hours a week
for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them their
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and
anyways
um with regards to
um
to
uh comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just who someone else
is today
this old client of mine he was about 85
when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written he made them out of gold
and he would hand those out and and he
had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that i didn't know about called the
pareto distribution which see i'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that's a pretty or a normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than very tall or very
short and weight is like that and lots
of things are normally distributed and
psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so here here's an example of
the pareto distribution huh you know
there's a rule of thumb that if you run
a company that 20 percent of your
employees do 80 of the work or the 20
percent of your customers are
responsible for 80 of your sales or the
20 of them are responsible for 80 of the
customer service calls same thing but
that's not exactly the rule the rule is
worse than that the rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work
what if you have a thousand employees
well then it's 30 and if it's 10 000
employees then it's a hundred
and this actually turns out to be a
rather ironclad rule it it it applies
across very very many situations it
applies for example to the mass of stars
and the size of cities so you can see
how universal it is as a law and it's
it's something like those that have more
get more and those that have less get
less that's the matthew principle right
to those who have everything more will
be given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's rife with
inequality so you know you you hear this
idea that i think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom 2 billion that's a pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law
it's no matter what society you study
you get a pareto distribution of wealth
you get a pareto distribution of number
of records recorded you get a pareto
distribution of number of songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and i'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although i am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
soviet union for example and in maoist
china they were trying at least in
principle to adjust inequality
but the cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but we do know that it's
inevitable and we also know that we
don't know how to regulate it so there
is inequality what that means is there's
always going to be people around that
are better at something than you are and
the and that's a that's a problem
because you can get jealous and you can
get bitter and you can get resentful and
worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look
i have this this friend of mine he told
me something so funny um he was he was
decrying his his lack of success in the
world and he compared himself to his
roommate
and uh
he said you know his roommate his
college roommate was doing much better
than he was and his bloody roommate was
elon musk it's like
really like it's like oh you're not
doing as well as elon musk well it's i
mean you can see it would take it rather
personally because they were roommates
and everything it wasn't like he was
doing badly like he was doing pretty
damn well it's like i'm not as good as
elon musk it's like yeah well you and
like seven billion other people you know
but but i thought it was instructive
because
well because you have to be careful who
you compare yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to email it is my
firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner that we are able to
and that that is a
fundamental
that's a fundamental import
i really believe in some sense it's of
cosmic import
in the same way that consciousness
itself is of cosmic import and
consciousness reflects being itself
and so and i do believe that we have
the
ability and the responsibility to
bring new creation into being and that
our ethical decisions
help us
that our ethical decisions that the
value of that new being is dependent
directly on the ethical decisions that
each of us make the positive emotion
that we find sustaining
is experienced in relationship to an
unachieved goal
it's hope that drives us forward we want
something and if we see ourself moving
towards that
then
we're we're in the grip of the positive
emotion that we find sustaining it isn't
the attainment attainment is satiating
attainment shuts down the system that
has been striving for that particular
object of attainment if you're hungry
and you eat you stop being hungry now
that's good because the hunger is gone
but that whole frame
disappears
you can no longer strive within that
frame and you need a new frame to strive
towards
and so technically and this is well
established as far as i'm concerned we
even know the drugs that people abuse
cocaine let's say amphetamines the ones
that are potent
sources of positive emotion
activate the system that regulates our
emotional response to evidence that
we're moving towards a desired goal
so cocaine for example
is an exhilarating drug it makes you
feel that things are worthwhile because
it hijacks the system that does make
indicate that things are worthwhile
so this is deeply this this striving
aspect is deeply rooted in in our in our
biology
for obvious reasons there's a higher
order moral principle that needs to be
brought into the situation and you sort
of described that right at the beginning
of the question because you said well
what partly what you do when you move
from an addicted state from a
psychological perspective is move from a
viewpoint of the gratification of
immediate desire and and maybe the
accumulation of things as a marker of
success to the notion that no you
actually have a higher purpose and that
higher purpose might involve being of
service that could be of service to
yourself which means you wouldn't be
addicted anymore because that's not a
good way of being of service to yourself
but of service to yourself and the
broader community however you might
define that that's a higher order
purpose and it can integrate your
motivations at at a level that doesn't
leave you at the whim of impulse that's
the purpose of a higher order motivation
not only do you have to move from point
a to b in life but point a is often a
very difficult place to be
because we're fragile and bounded and
mortal and limited and because we know
that and so one of the
implications of that as many great
religious traditions are at pains to
illustrate or demonstrate or proclaim
is that life is essentially suffering
and i believe that to be a fundamental
truth but
but perhaps not the most fundamental
truth because i think the most
fundamental truth is that despite the
fact that life is suffering people can
transcend that and partly the way they
transcend that is by pursuing things of
value and so that if there is no value
proposition at hand then you have no
meaning
to justify the difficult conditions of
your life and that's brutally difficult
for people you know nietzsche said
he who has a
why can bear any how
and you see and i've certainly seen this
as a clinical practitioner that people
who have no purpose in their life
are embittered by the difficulties of
their life and they become first bitter
and then resentful and then revengeful
and then cruel and there's plenty of
places to go past cruel that's just
where you start if you're really on a
downhill path you know we kind of have
this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if i can if i can put this
properly
that you have a certain delightful
wonderful positive freedom as a child
and then that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic way more people than you
think and part of that is because no
one's ever really encouraged them and so
the book is in part a matter of
encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in in check and then you can move
towards a state that's freer because
it's discipline first like look if
you're going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
freedom and so in virtually every
freedom that you have in life that's
true freedom is purchased at the price
of discipline you need a value hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top i would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that
each person is of divine value and that
the most appropriate way of interacting
with potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be at
the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and
so the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it
does that in a manner that's evil and
contaminated by malevolence and hatred
and vengefulness then it takes a pathway
that corrupts the world and makes things
worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character you have to be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well
and it might be so embarrassing that you
can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
fathom that that's actually who you are
but you know
jung described the fool
the archetypal figure of the trickster
and the fool as the precursor to the
savior to the redeemer and that's
unbelievable bit of wisdom because
what you meant was that
to put yourself together which is to
follow the path of redemption
to follow the redeemer
if the redeemer is a type of personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
or manifest
then this first step towards that is to
allow yourself to be a fool
right
it's because
you you don't know what you're doing
you have to admit that and there's going
to be a loss of ego or destruction of
ego arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that but you need the loss
of that arrogant ego because it's
precisely what's interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process mythologically
speaking that stops moral progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice what you're like so that
you could change properly you don't want
to sacrifice that part of yourself it's
probably associated with some delusion
that
helps you maintain
in uh
what you say a positive although very
fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort before you can
be a painter who can paint what's beyond
mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and and
even to some degree whatever creativity
you have is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is there places of
guidance and and there are places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines right i mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of that that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it and so then
the question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction this is
nietzsche's commentary on the catholic
church he's a great admirer of the
catholic church despite the fact that he
was also a radical
critic
critic of christianity said the cat see
the thing about the catholic church is
that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline
and once that discipline was established
then the disciplined mind could explode
in every direction which is precisely
what happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that when you're a
teenager and a young adult you have to
sacrifice everything you could have been
as a child to be the one thing that
you're aiming at but then that opens up
and and the universities are part and
parcel of that process and you need the
guidance because
the
the the library is too large to wander
through it unaided many times in life
people don't get what they want and they
need because they don't aim at it
and it's a hard lesson for people to
learn because they're cynical to begin
with and they presume that there's no
possible way of moving forward
but
it's not so unreasonable to assume that
you're not going to hit what you don't
aim at
or you're not going to hit what you aim
at and don't shoot at
and i've seen time and time again that
if people do put forward a vision for
what they regard as
worthy of pursuit which is something you
have to
determine in dialogue with yourself it's
like given the difficult preconditions
of existence
is there anything that you could
conceive of that you would regard as
sufficiently worthwhile so that you
would be
motivated to pursue it
it's a it's a it's a profound
philosophical question and it's not an
unreasonable one it's it's a good place
to start it's like well life is
difficult and enough to make you cynical
and bitter and perhaps enough to make
you cynical and bitter and suicidal and
homicidal and even genocidal
and it's not surprising in some sense
and then the question is well is there
something that you can pursue
that allows that to be
acceptable
or perhaps even desirable
which is something to do that justifies
the suffering
and it's hard to say what that would be
for each of you
it's something that you can discover
this is partly why nietzsche was wrong
nietzsche thought that after
god had died
that human beings would have to invent
their own values
but the psychoanalysts i would say jung
foremost among them
put forward a very powerful counter
claim which was that
while you can't invent values
they're already built into you
you have to discover them
and i think that's true for each person
it's like well what would justify you in
in the abandonment of your resentment
and hostility
what would be a sufficiently adventurous
goal the more radical the necessary
change the more pain that accompanies it
like the more opportunity as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out
and so the fact that people flee from
that is hardly surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better
the better
idea is to eat a little poison every day
so that you don't have to overdose in a
month it's something like that
and it is the case that i think because
you don't you aren't forced to first of
all you don't learn unless you're forced
to learn i know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote
to this but
apart from that
speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out
it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you it's because maybe it's
because they're convinced that there's
some way of forestalling the necessary
learning and there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility is to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can but you have to have a very
tragic
i would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and
that makes you desperate enough to learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video
because you are awesome if you want to
learn the habits to adopt the right
mindset with jordan peterson check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there we are
challenges and that they're
that and that in some sense those are
best construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what jung thought